alright it's your turn implement a
cursor loader in the forecast fragment
to load the cursor used in the cursor
adapter you want to pass 0 in for the
flags when you create the cursor adapter
as the loader will now be responsible
for Greek wearying when data changes
also it's easiest to have forecast
fragment implement the loader callbacks
if after you're doing all this your app
still displays the weather you've
probably done it right make sure to
check that you are using the support
library versions of all of our classes
otherwise you won't get Android 23
compatibility I provided the exact
import statements you need to use in the
instructor notes below